- [Instructor] We're asked to prove
that if a line is parallel
to one side of a triangle,
then it divides the other
two sides proportionally.
So pause this video and
see if you can do that.
And you might wanna leverage this diagram.
All right, so let's work
through this together.
So we can start with this diagram.
And what we know
is that segment ED is
parallel to segment CB.
So we can write that down.
Segment ED is parallel to segment CB.
And so segment ED is what
they're talking about.
That is a line or a line segment
that is parallel to one
side of the triangle.
So really given what we know,
and what's already been written
over here on this triangle,
we need to prove another
way of writing it,
another way of saying it divides
the other two sides proportionately,
is that the ratio
between the part of the
original triangle side
that is on one side of the dividing line
to the length on the other side
is going to be the same on both sides
that it is intersecting.
So another way to say
that it divides the other
two sides proportionately,
if we look at this triangle over here,
it would mean that the
length of segment AE
over the length of segment EC
is going to be equal to
the length of segment AD
over the length of segment DB.
This statement right over here,
and what I underlined up here
are equivalent given this triangle.
So the way that we can try to do it
is to establish a similarity
between triangle AED and triangle ACB.
So how do we do that?
Well, because these
two lines are parallel,
we can view segment AC
as a transversal intersecting
two parallel lines.
So that tells us that these
two corresponding angles
are going to be congruent.
So we could say that angle one
is congruent to angle three.
And the reason why,
is because they are corresponding,
corresponding angles.
I'm just trying to write
a little bit of shorthand.
This is short for corresponding angles.
That's the rationale.
And we also know that angle two
is congruent to angle
four for the same reason.
So angle two is congruent to angle four.
Once again, because they
are corresponding angles.
This time we have a different transversal,
corresponding angles
where a transversal
intersects two parallel lines.
And so now, if you look at
triangle AED and triangle ACB,
you see that they have two
sets of corresponding angles
that are congruent.
And if you have two sets
of corresponding angles,
that means that all of
the angles are congruent.
And you actually see that over
here, if you care about it,
but two is enough, but
you actually have a third
because angle, I guess you call it BAC
is common to both triangles.
And so we can say that triangle AED
is similar to triangle ACB,
ACB by angle similarity.
Similarity.
And then given that these two are similar,
then we can set up a proportion.
That tells us that the ratio
of the length of segment AE
to this entire side to AC,
is equal to the ratio of AD,
the length of that segment
to the length of the entire thing, to AB.
Now this implies, and I'm
just gonna start writing it
to the right here to save space.
This is the same thing
as the ratio of AE over,
AC is AE plus EC's length.
So AE's length plus EC's length,
and then this is going to be equal
to the length of segment AD
over segment AB, its length
is the length of segment AD,
AD plus segment DB, plus D B.
Now, really what I need to do
is figure out how do I
algebraically manipulate it
so I get what I have up here.
Let me scroll down a little bit.
So one way I could try to simplify this
is to essentially cross multiply,
that's equivalent to
multiplying both sides
by both of these denominators.
And we've covered that in other videos.
And so this is going to be equal
to the length of segment AE
times AD plus DB, those segment lengths,
that's gotta be equal
to length of AD times AE
plus the length of segment EC.
And I can distribute this over here.
I have length of segment AE
times length of segment AD
plus length of segment AE
times length of segment DB
is equal to length of segment
AD times length of segment AE
plus length of segment AD
times length of segment EC.
And let's see, is there anything
that I can simplify here?
We'll have AE times AD on both sides.
So let me just subtract AE
times AD from both sides.
And so then I'm just left
with this is equal to that.
So scroll down a little bit more
and let me actually just
rewrite this cleanly.
So I have AE times DB
is equal to AD times EC.
These are all the segment
lengths right over here.
Now, if you divide both sides by EC,
you're going to get an EC down here,
and then this would cancel out.
And then if you divide both sides by DB,
this will cancel out and you'll
get a DB right over here.
So if you just algebraically manipulate
what we just had over there,
you get that the length of segment AE
over the length of segment EC,
length of segment AE over
the length of segment EC
is equal to the length of segment AD, AD
over the length of segment DB,
which is exactly what we wanted to prove.
That this line right over here
that is parallel to this side over here,
divides the other two
sides proportionally.